let's go next to our friend Dante from
Florida Dante from Florida what's what
do you have for me today Dante Hey
because actually dontel dontel supporter
okay III we always had you as Dante and
I stand corrected on tell we will update
it in the system alright so this is what
a group thing um around what the left
should do go forward and I want to talk
about that for a little bit so like in
the 2020 much in the there's this idea
that people who agree with Bernie
Sanders platform his policy platform
that the best option that they have to
see those things implemented would be to
support your Biden and I just don't
think that's true I don't think there's
any evidences for that's true the best
way to see those policies implemented
would be to organize and try to pressure
congressional leadership and pressure
Donald Trump into implementing so second
dontel I want to make sure I understand
and and try to keep the phone a little
further from your mouth because you're
coming in very hot and we're having a
hard time modulating you so it sounds
like you're sort of setting up a let me
fight let me inquire are you setting up
a false choice or are you actually
saying that Trump as president and
pressuring him will be better than Biden
being president are you actually saying
it would be better for Trump to be
president and to pressure Trump rather
than for Biden to be president and to
pressure Biden that's not what I don't
think that you're not going to push Joe
Biden to the left you're not gonna push
him to the left to the point where you
get Medicare for all and the same with
Donald Trump going where you're going to
get Medicare for all is to force their
hand and to pressure them with protests
and calling them out the Democratic
leadership there are other ways to do it
on might how's the sunrise movement they
organized that sit-in and okay but one
second Don so let me make
because the the first assertion you made
unless I misunderstood was rather your
you disagree that electing Joe Biden is
the way to get progressive stuff done
you said that congressional leaders
should pressure Trump but then you said
neither Joe hold on a second hold on
hold on it we're not we're not gonna be
able to talk unless you I have to be
able to tell you what I heard and then
you can correct it okay okay okay you
first said you disagree with what you
called groupthink on the left that Joe
Biden is the best way to get Bernie
Sanders policies past you then said I
believe we are better off having
congressional leaders pressure Trump I
then asked are you saying you would
rather Trump than Biden because you
think we can get more from Trump you
then said no what I'm saying is either
way we're not getting Medicare for all
so how is it that we're going to if
either way we're not getting Medicare
for all how will we get it by pressuring
Trump to give it to us I think they
either would everything Medicare for all
I do when I think the first Joe Biden to
the left we're not gonna push your body
to the lab no that's not what you said
you can go back and listen to it you
said specifically we're not going to
push bot Biden to the left to support or
tomorrow yes right said you aren't we
aren't going to be able to get either of
them to do it but you open this or
whatever push them to the left all right
a conversation like this Dante I'm sorry
call call back a different day and we'll
try to start up again listen to the call
and you'll see exactly what you said